wir machen heute
xxl bommel gegen aussen richtig knusprig
und innen dass die inneren richtig schön
fluffig sind war ich wünsche dir könnte
das schmecken richtig lecker
[Musik]
hallo zusammen wir machen heute xxl mit
ich hab so lust drauf ich jetzt irgendwo
mal gesehen dass ich mir das muss ja
auch machen also wir nehmen uns
zuallererst kartoffeln schälen sie und
garen sie dann in salzwasser ich habe
die hier schon abgegossen ihr könnt
diesen gabel trick anwenden also wenn
die kartoffel locker von der gabel fällt
dann sind sie gar so bei mir hat
ungefähr zwölf minuten gedauert wenn die
große kartoffeln habt dann schneidet sie
schön klein damit sie nicht so lange
brauchen und jetzt werden sie erst mal
schön zerstampft
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt noch mal mit salz und
pfeffer gewürzt und die masse aber in
den kühlschrank getan denn sie sollte
schon abgekühlt sein jetzt kommt die
speisestärke mit der zuletzt quasi mit
den händen einfach nur die stärke
nochmal eingerührt ihr könnt natürlich
je nachdem wie sich eure kartoffeln
verhalten mehr oder weniger speisestärke
dazu geben also variierbar ruhig guckt
dass die masse richtig schön fest wird
und anschließend können wir sie auch
schon in ganz lange xxl kartoffeln
schneiden nebenbei erhält sich schon mal
mein frittierfett da gibt es ja den ganz
einfachen trick wenn ihr einen
schaschlikspieß rein haltet dann sollten
die bläschen nicht zu schnell aufsteigen
dann ist das fett so heißt auch nicht zu
langsam und ist es zu kalt sondern
gerade richtig dann braucht ihr auch
kein thermometer um das frittierfett
bereit zu machen von anschließend werde
ich sie einfach nur noch richtig schön
goldbraun frittieren
[Musik]
so ich habe jetzt hier meinen teil
koller mit abstand zwischen benutzer und
zwar habe ich ihr noch ein zentimeter
eingestellt so könnt ihr einfach
sichergehen dass alle kommen ist gleich
lang braucht natürlich könnte es auch
per augenmaß machen aber so habt ihr wie
gesagt den vorteil die werden alle
gleich also gleichzeitig schwimm gold
brauchen sie schon erfüllt voll lecker
aus und die mögen gerne mal so dass sie
sich eine aneinander also dass sie sich
gegenseitig anziehen da könnt ihr
einfach wichtig spielt die immer wieder
auseinander freeman und irgendwann
schwimmen sie dann wirklich auseinander
im feld das noch mal so als tipp das
fällt ihr merken wenn ihr das zubereitet
sobald ich die erste wartung übrigens
frittierte nehme ich mir immer so den
rest war ich hab's ja als quadrat quasi
ausgeschnitten damit den ästhetisch
aussehen und dann könnt ihr euch das
immer wieder aus rollen bis quasi kein
kartoffelteig mehr übrig bleibt
[Musik]
also wenn das mal kein
die sehen einfach richtig gut aus und
ich habe gerade alte fotos gemacht haben
schon reingebissen die sollen natürlich
schön frisch und schön warm ist wir
haben es leider nicht da daher müsst ihr
mit mir vorliegt sind außen richtig
knusprig und innen man erwartet glaube
ich eher dass alles knackig ist aber
viel geiler ist es dass sie innen
richtig schön fluffig sind ich wünsche
dir könnte das schmecken dazu noch in
welche tipps ketter mio die soße alles
was ich möchte und wie gesagt am besten
warm genießen einfach vom fernseher oder
nebenbei an einem sonntag wenn du etwas
gönnen möchte macht sie unbedingt nach
richtig lecker und wenn ihr mögt
schreibt mir gern weitere
rezeptvorschläge hier unten in die
kommentare und hinterlasst im video
gerne einen daumen nach oben den
algorithmus schön burschen dann sehen
wir uns auch bei meinem nächsten
[Musik]